オラ！オラぁ！
しゃーオラー
何だと？オラーオラ
何を隠そう俺は喧嘩が
弱い
喧嘩が弱いそれがどうした
引きこもって過ごしてきたわけだが
やっぱり男と言ったら喧嘩っしょ　なぁーーー？
というわけで俺はもっとてっぺんに登って最強の男になりてー
どんな男でも拳一つでぶっ飛ばすくらい俺はもっとBIGな男になりたいんだ
だが喧嘩が弱い体力も無い
そんな時俺はとある物に出会った
持ってこい！
Amazonで見つけた
あーこれだ　これを見つけたんだ
ktkr＝来たこれ
本当に強くなるのかどうか試してみたいと思うんでまじで（卍かな？）　おらっしゃー　チャリで来た
DVDも付いてるらしいので　実際にこの喧嘩本読んで　DVDを見て
完全喧嘩本を読んで
誰でも勝てるのか検証してみようと思う
卍
著作権的な関係で中身は見せられないので読んでるシーンを見て楽しんでくれ
周りにどんな敵がいるかわからねーからそういうこと考えて周囲を　状況の把握というのが大事
相手の顎を狙ってそのまま壁にぶつけて頭を狙う
よしよしよしよしよし
相手が掴み掛ってきたら髪の毛を下から掴み
壁に打ち当てましょう
こういうことか
あ、やっぱ一番大事なのは
正義を貫くということらしい
この本にそう書いてある
すげー良い本だった
実際に街に行ってヤンキーと戦ってみようと思う　行くぞあらぁぁぁ
大阪に来た
喧嘩で必ず勝てる本を読んだから
俺より強そうなヤンキーがいたらそいつと喧嘩をする
そこに強そうな奴がいます
あれがたい良くない？
今から俺が喧嘩吹っかけてくる
ぶっ飛ばしてやるから見とけよ
本読んだからまじで強いからな
がたいとか関係ない確実に俺が倒す
それが俺流だ
俺と怠慢で喧嘩してくれ
は？お前何しとんやこらぁ　おい皆来てくれ
オラ　何しとんじゃこら
オラオラオラオラ
今回字幕打たせてもらった”今日の一言”です
今日疲れてて字幕ちょっと手抜きです　すいません
次回からはしっかり打とうと思います<m(__)m>
おーーーー